One of our oldest and most popular videos,
just recently celebrated its fourth anniversary.
So we made this shirt to celebrate!
Because you may look at a tardigrade and you
might not assume that the two of you have
a lot in common, but like the resilient water
bear, I think we all have those days where
we feel a little chubby, misunderstood, and
not immortal.
So if you'd like to pick one up for yourself,
you can get them right now at microcosmos.store.
When was the last time you saw a puddle?
Was it recent—
perhaps some time in the past week, fresh
from a downpour?
Or has it been a long time since you’ve
seen rain, and so an even longer time since
your path has crossed a puddle?
If you can remember, do you know what you
did when you saw the puddle?
Did you hop around it, trying to keep your
clothes as pristine as possible?
Or did you have the complete opposite impulse
and jump right in the middle of it,
and splashing water everywhere.
Or maybe you leaned in closer and wondered
what’s in there, floating a few inches away in the
shallow depths at the edge of your feet?
If that last one sounds like something you
did (or maybe something you wish you had done),
you’re in good company.
Everything we’re watching right now came
from puddles around Warsaw that James, our
master of microscopes, collected samples from.
He waited for two days after it rained and
then wandered from puddle to puddle so he
could collect water to watch under the microscope.
That’s where he found these green algae
called pandorina.
This is not actually one algae, but rather
a group of them, bound together in a mucus-y
shell so they can form a colony.
You can see those individual members of the
colony better here, each a single green cell
living a conjoined existence with its neighbors.
Given enough light, these colonies quickly
reproduce, crowding the tiny puddles that
James gathers his samples from.
But James is not the first microscopist to
peer into a puddle.
In fact, if we look at the writings of one
of the original masters of microscopes, we
can transport ourselves in time and space
to the microcosmos of a 17th century Dutch puddle.
I’m of course talking about Antony van Leeuwenhoek,
a Dutch microscopist whose many letters to
the Royal Society of London contain our earliest
descriptions of microorganisms, or as he called
them “little animalcules”.
When Leeuwenhoek first mentioned these little
animalcules, not everyone believed him.
It was one thing to hear his description of
a bee stinger under the microscope.
People were familiar with bees and their stingers.
But an invisible world of tiny creatures—
tinier, according to Leeuwenhoek, than the
mites found on a cheese rind, well, that was
harder to imagine.
In a letter to the microscopist Robert Hooke,
Leeuwenhoek wrote,
“I suffer many contractions and oft-times
hear it said that I do but tell fairy tales
about the little animals.”
One of Leeuwenhoek’s letters started with
the following:
In 1675 I discovered living creatures in Rain
water which had stood but few days in a new
earthen pot.
This rainwater, along with the sampling methods,
observations, and experiments that Leeuwenhoek
described in his letters, would form the basis
of his own understanding of the microscopic world.
And so, in turn, it would form the basis of
many other’s investigations into the little
animals and the world they inhabit all around
us.
In a way then, every time you see a puddle,
you can think of it as a natural ode to the
early experiments that introduced us to the
microcosmos—
like little memorials to the history of microscopy.
Puddles are more than just reminders of history
though.
They are their own little worlds, placing
demands on the organisms living inside of them.
This cyst, for example, holds a rotifer that
is slowly waking up from a nap that had probably
protected it from a dry spell, before rain
had filled the puddle back up.
There is a rhythm to that kind of life, tied
to the wetness surrounding them.
In between rains, the organisms must find
a way to cope with their dry environment.
And when the world around them becomes wet
again, the organisms thrive, like this ciliate
that’s dividing so it can fill its watery
world up with clones.
These are boom and bust cycles taken to their
extreme, to a million little worlds that go
from not existing to existing when you just
add water.
So it’s no wonder microscopists have been
drawn to puddles for centuries, these little
pop-up microcosmos-es that reveal pockets
of life lying all around us.
This video of a vorticella comes to us from
a master microscopist in Florida named Curtis,
who was sampling driveway puddles to watch
under the Journey to the Microcosmos microscope.
We can see it in the middle of our screen,
perfectly still with its stalk extended long
until something comes along and spooks it,
sending the vorticella rapidly inward as it
contracts back towards the debris it’s attached
to.
This footage was submitted to us over at microcosmos.store,
where, if you’re interested, you can submit
your own footage to potentially be used in
a Microcosmos episode, because there are countless
worlds all around us waiting to be seen and
shared, and we’re looking forward to seeing
more of the worlds around you
fellow masters of microscopes.
And after everything we’ve learned today,
it feels right that the first video we would
be able to share from one of you comes from
a puddle, that it comes from a source that
shares so much with the home of Leeunwehoek’s
little animalcules despite originating centuries
later and thousands of miles away.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Don't forget right now you can head on over
to microcosmos.store both to submit some footage
if you like, but also to pick up our brand
new Tardigrade T-shirt celebrating the fourth
anniversary of our very first Tardigrade video.
Before we go, we also want to thank each and
every single one of our Patreon patrons, because
without them, this show could not exist.
And you're seeing some of their names on the
screen right now.
And if you would like to join those names
on the screen, you can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you'd like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check
out Jam and Jerms on Instagram.
And if you'd like to see more from us, there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.